- Welcome everybody.
Today we have the pleasure
of having Dr. Paula López Peña,
who is a postdoc with us
in the refugee program here at Yale,
presenting her work on the Causes
and Consequences of Ethnic
Violence in Myanmar.
Dr. López Peña has been teaching here
at the Departments of Economics.
And her areas of research
are applied microeconomics
and development economics.
She studies how non-cognitive skills
and adverse life events affect health
and labor market outcomes.
Her current projects
focus on entrepreneurship,
firm productivity, and the causes
and consequences of violence.
So thank you very much Paula,
and the floor is yours.
- Thank you very much
Teresa for the introduction,
and also for hosting this event.
We are delighted to be
presenting our work on the causes
and consequences of ethnic
violence in Myanmar today.
And here, the caveat is,
today, we're gonna be presenting results
from the decade prior to the
beginning of the pandemic.
My coauthors are here with me today.
Austin Davis from American University,
Mushfiq Mobarak from Yale,
and Jaya Wen from the
Harvard Business School.
We're all looking forward
to having your feedback and comments.
Feel free to ask me questions
directly at any time.
Just unmute yourself.
Or if you prefer,
you can just write your
question on the chat box
and one of us will answer your
question as soon as possible.
And with that,
I'm gonna get started.
And I want to start by briefly
introducing the context
for the persecution of
Rohingya movements in Myanmar.
As many of you may know,
Myanmar is one of the most
ethnically diverse countries on earth.
And almost since its foundation,
it has been torn apart by armed clashes
between the different ethnic militias
and the state's Armed
Forces, the Tatmadaw.
And of all ethnic groups,
the Rohingya Muslims who start out
for having been the most
severely persecuted minority.
They were stripped of citizenship in 1982.
And ever since then,
they have been relentlessly harassed,
both by the Tatmadaw
and sometimes by their
own neighbors next door.
Furthermore, there is growing evidence
that there has been a sharp increase
in the number of violent events
started in Rohingya Muslims,
since 2011, which was the year
in which Myanmar started as a country,
a transitioning to democracy.
The latest outbreak of violence
the infamous military crackdown
that took place in 2017,
alone, displaced over
700,000 Rohingya Muslims,
the vast majority of whom are
currently living in Bangladesh
in crowded refugee camps.
One of the facts
that we're going to present
to you today is that,
very large proportions of the
refugees living in Cox's Bazar
is that the vast majority of them
report having survived
or witnessed physical
assault, murder, rape,
and arson attacks.
And despite how pervasive
these narratives are,
what happened exactly
in the aftermath of the 2017 crackdown,
and why it happened,
remains highly contested.
And our paper will speak directly
to the two predominant narratives
and explanations for
what happened and why.
The first is that of the
international community,
which primarily agrees
that the kind of violence
that the Rohingya have been exposed to,
especially during and after 2017,
are a textbook example
of ethnic cleansing.
And that the evidence of mass killings
and mass gang rapes that
they have been exposed to
show a clear genocidal intent
on the side of the military.
On the other hand,
the compelling narrative
is that of the former civilian
government of Myanmar,
now the post,
former State Councilor Aung San Suu Kyi
declared that it was still not easy
to establish clear patterns of events,
and that it's possible
that some refugees might
have provided inaccurate
or exaggerated information.
So the bottom line is the
government of Myanmar argues
that there is no evidence
that the persecution of Rohingya Muslims
or violence against Rohingya
Muslims has been widespread,
or systematic.
Our goal with this paper is to
provide quantitative evidence
to complement the existing
qualitative narratives,
those that have been told
by refugees themselves.
and reported by numerous
journalistic accounts
from reporters in the field.
And the two main contributions
that these paper makes,
is, on the one hand,
we're gonna exploit a
very detailed data set
that contains daily
data on conflict events
from across Myanmar for over a decade.
And this makes our conclusions
less susceptible to cherry-picking,
and less susceptible
to perhaps over-reliant
on arguably inaccurate recollections.
And in doing so,
what we help us to provide
a descriptive in-depth set of facts
indicative of a long
term, mythological pattern
on the side of the military,
and how the military
treats differently Rohingya
from other ethnic minorities.
And importantly, our data will allow us
to tell you a causal story
on one important driver of violence.
And our focus here is going to be that,
violence has economic motivations.
And this side of the story
has often been overlooked.
(mumbles)
In many instances,
the conflict has been characterized
as being under underlined by
deep-rooted religious hatred,
or ethnic tensions.
In doing so,
we're gonna contribute to a
very broad economics literature
on ethnic conflict and
interstate conflict.
But our goal with this
paper was also to try
to contribute to the ongoing policy debate
on how the international community
could potentially help
prevent the military
or decentralize the military
from continue to engage in
violence against civilians,
and perhaps how to inform
the humanitarian response
to address the psychological toll
that these refugees bring with them.
The response that we're
gonna present to you,
and our story,
is a structure around a
three-prong empirical approach.
Firstly, we're going to present you
a set of difference-in-difference
regressions
that are going to help us establish
whether or not there were
systematic economic motivations
driving ethnic persecution in Myanmar.
And the hypothesis we're
going to test is that,
in periods when rice prices
are particularly high,
in regions that are more
suitable for rice cultivation,
conflict might increase.
And if this is the case,
this is evidence that
there are systematic economic
motivations behind violence.
The second part of the
paper is going to be based
on vector auto-regressions, or VARs.
This is a statistical framework
that allows us to document
how different actors
involved in this conflict
behave over time,
and how they respond to
one another's action.
And this is gonna be very
helpful for us to compare
the way in which the military
has treated the Rohingya
compared to other ethnic minorities.
And lastly, we're gonna present you
a set of very basic
yet hard to come by summary and statistics
on the prevalence of depression
and past experiences with trauma
among refugees currently
living in Cox's Bazar.
And this is to try to pay
the enormous human toll
of the ethnic persecution
we're trying to describe and explain.
And we're going to start
with the first section,
the rice differences-in-differences
approach.
Here, as I was saying earlier,
the motivation or the
goal is to understand
whether changes in our
international price of rice
could lead to an increase
or a decrease in conflict
in areas that are more
suitable for land cultivation,
which would then suggest
that ethnic violence is
underlined by economic markets.
And our empirical analysis
is going to be based
on a series of stylized facts
that make it particularly suitable
for asking the question at hand.
The first is that,
rice is the most important
staple food in Myanmar.
It accounts for over 40%
of agricultural production.
And in particular,
most of the rice cultivated
the country is wetland rice,
which you can see portrayed in the picture
on the bottom left of this slide.
Secondly, Myanmar is a price taker
on the international global market.
Even though it exports
a very large fraction
of its domestic crop, nearly 10%,
the amount is still too small
to affect international rice prices.
And therefore this is going
to be a core assumption
underlying our analysis.
Myanmar is a price-taker,
and hence changes in international prices
are going to be active
as an exogenous shock
to domestic prices.
The last stylized fact that
underlines our analysis
and that it is going to help us
identify the causal effect of
changes in prices is the fact
that wetland like rice has very
specific geoclimatic needs.
If you look at a map of Myanmar,
and even within Rakhine State,
what you're gonna see is that
the suitability of different regions
both within the country
and within the state,
for growing rice is gonna vary widely.
Here what we present is
an index of suitability
of different plots of land,
both in Myanmar as a whole
and Rakhine where the Rohingya live.
And what this shows is that
there is a lot of variation
in how suitable some
places are for growing rice
relative to others.
And here we're gonna
exploit a very rich data set
coming from the FAO,
the Global Agro-Ecological Zone data set
that contains very fine
granular information
on how good a certain area is
for cultivating and growing rice.
And did I mention,
suitability is going to be
composed by a number of variables
such as precipitation,
temperature, quality soil, etc.
Now, our empirical strategy is designed
to test two potential mechanisms
through which changes in rice
prices could affect conflict.
The first is the so
called rapacity effect.
What this tells us is that,
if the price of a commodity goes up,
that means that the commodity
becomes more valuable.
And therefore, this creates incentives
for people to try to
appropriate the commodity,
or even the inputs utilized
to produce that commodity.
In our context, that would be land.
So in this case,
a positive shock to the price of rice
would increase conflict
in areas that are particularly
suitable for growing rice.
But at the same time,
rice is a very labor-intensive crop.
It requires a lot of manpower,
and a lot of human effort.
And therefore, it's possible
that if the price of
the commodity goes up,
the salary of agricultural
workers growing it increases.
And these positive shock to labor income
acts as a disincentive
to engage in other economic activities
that might cost time.
For instance, engaging in appropriating
or looting rice from someone else,
which might also have some form of cost,
some form of punishment.
So in this case,
this is what we call the
opportunity cost mechanism.
In this case,
a positive shock to rice
prices has a pacifying effect.
And what is interesting
about analyzing the effect
of shocks to rice prices,
is that it could go either way.
It's possible that there
is a rapacity effect
in some places,
and an opportunity costs in other places.
And here is when it becomes interesting
that we're studying Myanmar.
Myanmar is the setting
where one of the conflict actors
has a much stronger military capability
than all other actors that we're studying,
than any other ethnic militia.
And therefore what we are
going to argue is that,
in our setting,
these forces might be particularly strong,
especially in areas
that are highly suitable
for land cultivation.
And these makes ideal our
difference-in-difference set up.
This is our baseline specification.
This is the regression
that we're gonna run.
To begin with,
across the whole country
using conflict data from across Myanmar.
Our outcomes of interest are described
on the left hand side, the y's.
We're gonna focus on three
subsets of conflict outcomes.
The first is violence against civilians
perpetrated by any conflict
actor in the country.
The second is a subset of that outcome,
violence against civilians,
in this case, perpetrated by state forces.
And the last is gonna be
looting or property damage.
And on the right hand
side of the regression,
we're gonna have an interaction term.
The first component of
which is land suitability.
And this measure summarizes
how good a certain
township is, to grow rice.
So this is the average quality
or the average level
of suitability of land
in a certain township
to cultivate rice.
And this is gonna be multiplied
by an index of rice prices.
And here, what we do is
aggregating rice prices
for the three most commonly grown
and sold types of rices
domestically in Myanmar
on a certain month year.
So these will be the equivalent
to thinking about rice,
or the average price of rice,
for instance, in January 2019.
And then four, the
coefficient of interest,
and the one which we're gonna show to you
in a couple of slides, is beta.
The one that is gonna capture
whether an increase in the price of rice
is going to lead to increased conflict
in areas that are more
suitable for land cultivation.
Now, we're gonna also add a
vector of control variables
just to ensure that the fact
that some months are always
different every year,
and that some townships are different
across the decade that we observed,
that these two effects
don't bias our estimates.
And we're also going to add some controls
for latitude and longitude,
as well as a dummy variable
to control for whether a
township is coastal or not.
And lastly, we are going to
instrument domestic prices
using international prices.
And this is to address
a potentially important
source of endogeneity
in our setting,
which is, it's possible
or we have reasons to believe
that the level of conflict
in a certain township
could affect the price
of rice domestically.
But we think it's highly unlikely
that conflict in a certain
township in Myanmar
is gonna have an effect
on international prices.
And that's what makes this
a very good instrument.
Reassuringly, we've
tested for the correlation
between these two variables.
It's very high,
so we have a very strong (mumbles)
And just to assume into how
we wanna interpret the beta,
why beta is the coefficient of interest.
This is because beta is going to allow us
to test our null hypothesis,
which is that economic forces
do not drive ethnic conflict in Myanmar.
And hence, both the magnitude
and the significance of beta
contain important information for us.
If beta is very close to zero,
not statistically significantly
different from zero,
then we would not be able
to argue based on our data,
that there exists
systematic economic forces
driving violence behind the scenes.
However, if beta is different from zero,
regardless of whether
it's positive or negative,
we take that as evidence
that there are economic motivations
driving ethnic violence in Myanmar.
And in particular, if beta is negative,
what this tells us is that,
an increase in rice prices is gonna lead
to a decrease in conflict
in areas that are more
suitable for land cultivation,
therefore, indicating that
there are economic forces
driving ethnic conflict
and that the opportunity
cost mechanism dominates.
So the shock is pacifying.
Conversely, if beta was positive,
what this indicates is that
in response to a positive
shock to international prices,
conflict is higher in areas
that are more suitable
for land cultivation.
And what this means is that
the rapacity mechanism dominates.
So the bottom line
before jumping on the main results table,
beta contains important information
that allows us to test
our null hypothesis.
We're gonna just dive into it.
Here, in these table,
each of the columns
represent a regression.
And the bottom row indicates
the outcome of interest
of each regression,
the left hand side.
Starting with column one,
what these represent is a regression
of the number of incidents
involving violence against civilians
in a certain township,
in a certain month.
And in column two,
we're gonna look at
a slightly different
version of this variable,
which is the number of
incidents of violence
against civilians in a township,
but we're gonna divide that
by the population size of
that township in millions.
And this is to account for the possibility
that conflict is not
linear in population size.
And lastly, the third column,
in the third column,
what we're gonna represent
is a binary variable
that takes value one,
if we observe even only
one instance of violence
against civilians in a
certain township month,
and zero otherwise.
And this is gonna help us address concerns
over measurement error.
Sometimes, it's very hard
to keep an accurate log of conflict,
especially in Myanmar,
a country where there
is no free journalism,
and it's very hard to report
what's happening on the ground.
So we might think that
whether there were three
or four events,
is not as important
as whether there was even
one single event in a month.
And this is why these binary variable
might bring additional information.
So these things are beta.
This is the coefficient of interest.
And what we see is that across the board,
beta is positive,
and is statistically
significantly different from zero.
And if you remember from
the previous slides,
what this means is that,
indeed, ethnic conflict
in Myanmar is underlined
by economic motives,
and the rapacity effect dominates.
So increases in the price of rice
leads to increases in conflict
in areas that are more
suitable for rice cultivation.
And this is true for the three
main types of conflict events
that we consider.
Violence against civilians by any force,
violence against civilians
by the state forces,
and looting and property damage.
So this is for the country as a whole.
But of course,
one of the goals of
the paper is to explain
what happens within Rakhine State,
what happens in the land
where the vast majority
of the Rohingya live,
and see whether these patterns apply
in that setting as well.
So we reproduce the same regressions,
but restrict it only two
townships in Rakhine State.
And this is what we find.
The caveat here is that
the number of observations
drops significantly,
and this makes us lose
the statistical power.
When looking at the entirety of Myanmar,
we had nearly 34,000 observations.
When we restrict our
analysis to Rakhine state,
we have less than 1700.
And despite this,
what we have seen is that
beta, again is always positive.
The magnitude is very similar
to that observing the analysis
at the national level.
And in some cases,
the coefficient is even
statistically significant,
even though we've lost a lot of power
by restricting our analysis
to a narrow geographic area.
So we take these as weak evidence
that the general pattern
that we've seen in
Myanmar economic motives
seem to be explaining
in part ethnic conflict,
seems to apply in Rakhine State.
But there seems to be a lot
that these alone cannot explain,
and this is what we're gonna try to tackle
in the next section.
Provide a deeper look
into why the Rohingya
conflict might be different.
And here we've done a
bunch of robustness checks,
just to show you that these
results are not sensitive
to small variations in specifications.
We're happy to go over those
perhaps at the end of the presentation
in the interest of time.
Now, I wanna move on
to the second section,
in which we show you
vector auto-regression
just to remind ourselves
what the purpose of this
part of the analysis was.
VAR offers a statistical framework
that helps us understand and document
how different conflict
variables evolve over time,
and how different conflict
actors respond to each other.
The core assumption underlying
this kind of analysis
is that, each conflict variable,
say, the behavior of the Tatmadaw,
the response of the Tatmadaw
to an attack by an ethnic militia,
is gonna be a function of itself,
and all other variables.
So this is to say,
how the Tatmadaw decides to respond today
to an attack by an ethnic militia
is gonna depend on the whole history
of past behavior by the Tatmadaw
and the behavior by the
ethnic militia in the past.
We're also going to make some additional
but fairly reasonable assumptions
to shut down reflection problems.
The way to think about these
is akin to what happened
when you face a circular
reference in Excel,
when the value of two cells
that depend on each other
cannot be simultaneously be determined
and you get an error message.
We're gonna make
just the minimum level
of assumptions necessary
to prevent these from
happening in our case.
And here's how we're going
to interpret the VAR analysis
in our context.
We're going to show
you a series of graphs,
that documents what happens on a day
when an ethnic militia attacks.
How does that ethnic militia
behave in subsequent days,
whether they keep hitting
or whether they retreat completely,
and how the Tatmadaw responds
over the following 30 days.
And this is gonna help us establish
whether the Tatmadaw treats
different ethnic minorities
in exactly the same way,
or whether they treat perhaps
the Rohingya differently.
We want to be very upfront
in that we're not gonna
make a causal interpretation
for these findings.
We are gonna think about these graphs
as providing an in depth and useful,
descriptive account of
retaliation patterns.
But we cannot make a causal claim.
Our data doesn't allow us
to establish why ethnic
militias may attack
in the first way,
or why the Tatmadaw might
respond in a certain way.
What we see in this graph is that,
following an attack on day one,
an attack that is perpetrated
by a Rohingya militia,
what we observe is that
on subsequent days,
there are no follow-up attacks.
So Rohingya militias attack,
and then they retreat.
We observe that the level of conflict
goes back to baseline
levels almost immediately.
They don't engage on additional conflicts
on subsequent days.
Now, the graph on the right
describes the response of the Tatmadaw
to that precipitating event,
that initial violent incident
in which the Rohingya
militia is the perpetrator.
And what we observe is that,
on day one, the Tatmadaw
responds to one initial attack,
one conflict event,
with 1.5 conflict events.
And not only that,
what we see is that the Tatmadaw,
not only perpetrates at counter attack,
which is 1.5 times as powerful
as the initial incident
that triggers conflict,
but they hit back one week later,
with almost the same force.
So the Tatmadaw does not
respond to violent incidents
initiated by Rohingya militia
on a one on one basis,
but they respond with
disproportionate force immediately,
and one week later.
And they continue to engage
in smaller counter attacks
for a long period of time.
And we take these as evidence
that the Tatmadaw responds very heavily
to a violent incident initiated
by the Rohingya militia.
Now, the question of interest here is,
does this mean that the Tatmadaw
is treating the Rohingya
in a particularly harsh way?
Or do they systematically
respond to militia attacks
regardless of their
ethnicity in a similar way?
In the paper,
we look at how the Tatmadaw responds
to the 10 most important ethnic militias,
based on the number of conflict events
in which they were engaged
over the past decade.
And here, we're gonna present
you a comparative analysis
of the two most important ethnic militias.
The first is the Kachin.
Understanding how the
Tatmadaw treats the Kachin
compared to the Rohingya, is important
because the Kachin is a much
more active ethnic militia.
They are engaged
in a much larger number
of conflict incidents
than the Rohingya militia,
and they are not Buddhists,
they are Christians.
So one might think
that if the conflict
is partially underlined
by religious hatred,
being Christian could
be a potential trigger
for a disproportionate response.
But that's not what we observe.
What we observe is that,
on a day when there is
one violent incident
in which the Kachin
militia is the perpetrator,
the Tatmadaw responds immediately
but responds with the
same amount of force,
responds with exactly one violent event,
one violent conflict incident.
And then we see that immediately after,
both parties retreat.
We don't see that the conflict escalates.
We see that for as long as we have data
for the following few weeks,
the conflict goes back to baseline level.
They respond to one another
with proportionate force.
Now, what happens with the Rakhine?
There ethnic Rakhine is also
a good benchmark in this case,
because they live in the
same state as the Rohingya.
The difference between the
Rakhine and the Rohingya is that
the Rakhine are Buddhists.
They are not ethnically similar
to the majority Burma in the country,
but they are Buddhists.
And what we see similar
to what we observe,
in the case of the Kachin,
on days when we observe a violent incident
in which the Rakhine
militia is the perpetrator,
we observe an immediate
response by the Tatmadaw,
but they respond with proportionate force.
They respond to one violent incident
with one violent incident.
And following this bilateral clash,
both parties seems to retreat.
The level of conflict falls very quickly,
back to baseline levels.
The conflict does not escalate.
So taking together,
what these findings suggest is that,
the way in which the Tatmadaw
treats Rohingya Muslims
is indeed very different
to how they treat other ethnic minorities.
And these seems to be in sharp contrast
with the argument employed
by Aung San Suu Kyi.
That the violence that we
observe is not systematic,
and it's driven by the
whole history of events
between the Rohingya ethnic
militia and the Tatmadaw.
Now, so far, our data and
our story has been silent
on why the Tatmadaw is
treating the Rohingya
in such a different way.
And here, we cannot argue,
we have a good answer for this question.
But our data set can speak
to one of the theories
for why this is happening,
that has gained the most
traction in recent years.
A growing number of scholars,
both in South Asia and
based outside of the Myanmar
have argued that the rise
in Buddhist nationalism
in anti-muslim sentiments
in the general population in Myanmar,
has allowed the Tatmadaw
to systematically target
and killing Rohingya
Muslims with impunity.
And one story that seems to be supported
by a number of qualitative studies
and even accounts by
journalists in the field,
is that, a particular form of hate speech,
which is Facebook posts,
and nationwide protests
organized by very highly
respected Buddhist monks
have helped spark spread rumors
about Muslims have stoke fears
about a potential Muslim invasion.
And this has helped build a narrative
about how threatening
Rohingya Muslims are.
And these has not just justified
many instances of communal violence,
but has helped the military attack,
knowing that there wouldn't
be a domestic backlash.
What we don't know is whether it's true
that these growth in hate speech,
and this growing number
of anti muslim protests
that were organized by Buddhist monks
effectively predict military intervention.
We don't know whether these
interventions were followed
by a crackdown on Muslim civilians.
And this is exactly the hypothesis
that our data allows us to test.
We have a daily log of
protests organized by Buddhists
and by civilians,
both in Rakhine State and Myanmar.
And what we observe
what the data tells us,
is that for every protests
organized by Buddhist monks,
in which they propagated rumors,
negative rumors about Muslims
or they tried to make a case
that Muslims don't belong in Myanmar,
these protests was followed
between 10 days and 20 days after
by an increase in the number of incidents
that are classified as violence
against Rohingya civilians
and were perpetrated by the Tatmadaw.
Again, we want to be very cautious here
in describing these results.
We cannot claim that
anti-muslim monk protests
are causing an increase
in the number of violence
against civilian incidents
perpetrated by the Tatmadaw.
What we are trying to suggest is that
these evidence seems
consistent with the hypothesis
that there is an implicit coordination
between some sections
of the monastic order
and the military.
And now I'm gonna jump to the
last section of the analysis,
the consequences of the
crisis understood as the,
by these we mean the
enormous mental health poll
of ethnic violence on the survivor.
And for this part of the analysis,
we are going to use data
from the Cox's Bazar Panel Survey.
This a longitudinal study
that monitors living conditions
and physical and health
outcomes in Cox's Bazar.
This panel survey is the result
of a collaboration between
well, the coauthors of this paper
and a number of researchers
from the GAGE ODI team
and The World Bank.
We ran a baseline survey
between April and July 2019.
And what we did was,
surveying representatives
of sample of refugee
and local households in Cox's Bazar,
and asking them a series of questions
to assess their experiences with trauma
and their mental health.
And our instruments contain both closed
and open ended questions,
therefore, allowing us to
look deeper into the data
or try to provide an interpretation
for what the quantitative
analysis was telling us.
And here is the first series
of the stylized facts.
What we found is that,
very large proportions
of Rohingya refugees,
regardless of the year in which
they arrived in Cox's Bazar,
have experienced at
least one trauma event.
Here, I wanna bring your
attention to column two.
What this tells us is that
over 87% of all Rohingya refugees
who escaped their 2017
outbreak of violence,
have experienced at
least one trauma event.
And nearly one of three of these refugees
have experienced more
than five trauma events.
Now, we have pointed here
some of the most commonly
reported forms of trauma
they have experienced in first person
or have witnessed.
And when you look at the
sample size of the panel,
and the fraction of refugees
who report having survived
near death experiences
or torture, or having witnessed
the murder of a family
member or a close friend,
it becomes increasingly difficult
to believe the narrative
offered by the government
that these were isolated events.
Nearly 2000 people in our sample
report having survived
near death experiences.
Now, if you look at column three,
this contains information
about the level of trauma
to which previously
arrived Rohingya refugees
have been exposed.
And what we see is that those who arrived
even before the most violent
outbreak of violence,
more than 83% also
reported having survived
at least one trauma event.
So even though the fraction
of respondents reporting each trauma event
seems a little bit lower,
in most cases,
the difference is not significant.
What we find is compelling evidence
that the violence the
Rohingya had been exposed to
are not isolated events.
And it is highly unlikely
that so many people have
inaccurate recollections.
Now, before moving forward,
we wanted to acknowledge a fact
that initially caught us by surprise,
which is, very large
numbers of Bangladeshi hosts
also reported having had
experiences with trauma.
These are qualitatively different.
In many instances,
these were cases of domestic violence.
But what we found was
important to communicate
is that the Rohingya refugees
is a severely traumatized population
arriving in a host country
where the natives have also been exposed
to very traumatizing experiences,
and therefore might have
psychological needs.
And this is gonna be important
for thinking about how to design
the humanitarian response.
And this speaks about how high priority
psychological support services
might be in this setting,
and not just to refugees.
This is the last series of results
we're going to present to you today.
And surprisingly, what we observe is that,
Rohingya refugees have very high
prevalence rates of depression.
If we were to aggregate across influxes,
and across genders,
what we observe is that one
in three Rohingya refugees
meets the symptom criteria for depression.
The prevalence of depression
is also very high among hosts.
One in four, in this case,
meet the symptom criteria for depression.
And we're gonna show you
how this compares with
other refugee populations
and the general population in The US.
We wanna be clear here
that the goal of this comparison
is not to try to minimize
the experiences of refugees
who have been resettled
in other countries.
This is just to qualify
our use of the word high
rates of depression.
When we mean that the rates
of depression in refugee camps
are alarmingly high,
this is what we mean.
They are between twice
and three times as high
as those among Syrian refugees
who have been resettled
in high income countries,
survivors of the Fukushima disaster,
and four times as high as
The US general population.
And now to conclude,
in this paper, we have shown you
that the persecution of
ethnic minorities in Myanmar
has economic motives.
We have also shown you
that the persecution of Rohingya
Muslims is very different
or represent a very different
retaliation pattern,
when you compare to how the Tatmadaw
has treated other ethnic minorities.
And here we point at a potential reason
why the Tatmadaw has gotten away with it,
which is there might be
an implicit coordination
with ultra-nationalist Buddhist monks.
And lastly, we have shown
you that all of these matters
because the human cost of
ethnic violence is very large,
both on the refugee population
and on the population
that they're hosting.
Now we have two highly
vulnerable populations
living in a very small area
and competing for psychological
services that are scarce.
And I think I'm gonna conclude here.
I promised Teresa that I was
gonna finish a bit earlier
to leave room for questions and answers.
We look forward to your feedback,
comments and suggestions.
Thank you very much.
So maybe Elisabeth,
do you wanna get started?
I don't know Teresa, how
do you wanna do this?
I would also like to invite my coauthors
to join the conversation
and answer directly.
- Hi, good afternoon, everybody.
Thanks very much.
A number of questions for you.
Does anybody take seriously
the Burmese government's narratives?
So it seems to me
to have that to be your
overarching takeaway
seems, you know, a kind
of oddly weak conclusion
of a lot of careful inferential work.
Now, it may be important
to do that for various policy reasons,
but it just seems to me
that it kind of pulls
the punch, so to speak,
of what you are demonstrating empirically.
A second question is
whether the VAR graphs,
they don't seem to me to be capturing
what on my read of some of
the International reports is,
attacks initially in 2016,
then in August 2017
by the ARSA,
followed by a wave of
ethnic cleansing violence,
that pushes the Rohingya away out,
imprison some, kills many and so on.
And so that there's (mumbles)
by kind of seeing one event
and then okay, it's disproportionate
in terms of the count,
and it's nice to see a timeline.
But that's not capturing the
intensity of the violent,
which is usually the way
disproportionality is measured,
which we know in this case is huge.
And also doesn't seem to capture that
the way in which these isolated attacks
were followed by these waves
of forced displacement.
So I'd like to understand more
how you're seeing those.
And then a third question is,
can you disaggregate between
the economic motives?
So you broke out property
damage and looting,
but not by actor,
not by perpetrator,
whether that's The Tatmadaw,
or presumably civilian members of,
I don't know, ethnic gangs
or something like that.
But under the rapacity,
you had two different motives, right?
One is grabbing rice,
and the second is grabbing land.
And it would be (mumbles)
That would seem to be really
important to understand
in terms of the durability of
displacement of the Rohingya.
So if you can speak to that,
that would be very helpful.
And then my last question is
a question not about the talk,
but about the abstract,
which says that,
there's a line that says
that the Tatmadaw use
violence against the Rohingya
to incapacitate the group,
as opposed to merely deterring
or responding to attacks
from Muslims and militias.
And then you say later,
and that you showed very nicely.
Then you say the Tatmadaw
deliberately targets
and kills Rohingya civilians,
but not civilians of
other minority groups.
You didn't show that,
and you know, the record
of human rights violations
in the north and northeast of the Kachin
and the other ethnic groups,
civilians of those ethnic
groups, is very long standing.
So I'm just wondering what
your position is on that.
Thanks very much.
- Thank you very much for
the excellent questions.
I'm gonna try to address all of them.
And thank you very much
for the thankful comments.
So I'm gonna try to go in order.
With regards to whether
anyone takes seriously
the Burmese claims,
they do domestically.
And to the extent that we believe
that having the endorsement
of voters and citizens
have allowed them to continue this attacks
and escalate over time,
we thought that it was important
to confirm that the
international narrative
should be believed domestically.
We understand you might
think it's very naive
that we think
that this paper might change
the perception domestically,
but we still felt it was important to say.
Now, the comment is well
taken in the sense that,
given the audience we have today,
perhaps that was the point
that did not need to be emphasized,
as opposed to all those
that would have been a better ending.
That point is very well taken.
We're also hoping perhaps this
paper could help make a case
in front of the International
Court of Justice.
We think but that this
quantitative approach
complements very well they
existing qualitative narratives
that have been easily disputed
or dismissed by the government of Myanmar.
So we're hoping maybe
that helps make these
additional contribution,
which is a policy-oriented one.
Yes, now moving to the second question,
you are absolutely right,
in that the VAR capture responses
on average over 10 years.
And therefore the 2017
events are highly diluted,
and they're to some, again, masked.
Here, the goal of the VAR was to show
that there has been a broader pattern
of systematic violence against Muslims
before and after the outbreak of violence.
Because one of the
claims that we're hearing
about what motivates this conflict
is that there are sudden
outbreaks of religious hatred,
and then violence escalates
and retreats very quickly.
And we were trying to offer,
perhaps a longer term
vision for what happened.
There is violence
ongoing most of the time,
even if that goes unnoticed.
So the VAR are portraying
that average level of conflict over time,
and how the Tatmadaw retaliates or behaves
outside of major outbreaks of violence.
But you're exactly right,
the VAR don't speak to
what happened in 2017.
That is exactly right.
With regards to the third question,
can we disaggregate
between economic motives?
This is an excellent point.
Unfortunately, at the moment,
our data does not allow us
to distinguish between
rice and land grabbing.
We fully acknowledge
that this is a very important distinction.
This is something we're still working on.
What we're gonna try to
do to address this concern
that we're taking very seriously
is look at existing maps of
what happened to the land
that has been expropriated
from the Rohingya
using satellite data.
But this is an ongoing process.
It is one that we expect is
gonna take a few more weeks.
So we don't have it today,
but it's a work-in-progress.
And then with regards to the
comment about the abstract,
that line I think has been removed.
We have now changed a little bit
how we explain our findings,
and we no longer refer,
we no longer label the
motives of the Tatmadaw
as incapacitation or retaliation purely
because we acknowledge that
our data does not allow us
to perfectly answer that question.
And then embedded in question number four,
you're absolutely right
that our VAR show an
average number of attacks
on civilians of other ethnic minorities
that we're very much aware exist,
and these are completely masked.
Because in levels like when
you average out over 10 years,
then these seem to be much lower.
So this is a clear drawback of using VAR's
at least 10 years of daily data
to portray or characterize
other ethnic conflicts.
We do show events in which
civilians have been targeted.
And I guess that if we were to
use a slightly different unit
or a different definition,
it would pop by
that these civilians
have also been attacked.
At the moment, it doesn't.
I need to think a little bit more
about how to combine VAR
with perhaps other ways
of displaying our results
such that we paint a better
and more accurate picture
on what's happening
in other states like Kachin.
So thank you very much for
these excellent comments.
I've taken notes.
We're gonna be working on this
over the next coming weeks.
Oh, I think we should use that also,
adding some additional responses.
Thank you, Mushfiq.
It is complementing what I just said.
Yeah.
Do we have any more hands?
Oh, I see Hannah.
Have you found documented (indistinct)
That's a very good question.
I want to answer.
Please let me know
if I haven't addressed any of
the questions on the chat box.
I wanted to answer to the question
on whether we have found
or documented empirical results
on the economic consequences
of these ethnic violence
such as the economic or employment loss,
presumably, among refugees.
I would say we have some
descriptive statistics.
But we are trying to work
to produce a new set of
preliminary results on this topic.
We think it's very important.
So I'm gonna respond on behalf of Austin.
We have been working a lot
on this part of the analysis.
The short answer is, we're working on it,
and we will, eventually.
- [Mushfiq] So I can just
give a little bit of detail
on what we find on the economic side.
So here, you know, the data, again,
are collected on the
Bangladesh side of the border
after the displacement.
And we collected that,
you know, the displacement
occurred in 2017, July 2017.
That's when the mass exodus of Rohingya
moved into Bangladesh.
I should say the latest exodus,
'cause there were prior mass exodus.
And so we have data.
We collected data on the economic
situation of the Rohingya.
So let's say the camp population.
That's one group.
The second group is Rohingya
who were already present in
Bangladesh prior to 2017.
And then a third group is
what we call host communities.
So Bangladeshis who are
living near the camps.
And then as a contrast,
we also have Bangladeshis living
a little bit further away
from the camps, okay?
And so the comparison we
can draw from these data is,
how are the Rohingya doing
relative to Bangladeshis
who live near the camp?
Because the survey was
administered to both those groups.
And the other thing we can
do is retrospectively ask,
okay, what are you doing right now?
What do you have right now?
What is your employment
income assets right now?
And what was it on,
like, say, first quarter of 2017,
before the displacement?
And so one of the main things
that you learn from that
data are that, like,
if you look at the entire
distribution of the Rohingya,
and let's look before 2017,
before they were displaced, right?
The entire distribution in
terms of income, assets, right?
Look, very similar
to the distribution of Bangladeshis
living on the other side of
the river in Cox's Bazar,
and Ukhiya district where the camps are.
If anything, the Rohingya had,
you know, the population density
on that side of the border is lower
so they had a bit more assets.
So a bit more land than Bangladeshis did
say in February 2017, okay?
And then what is observed
right after the displacement
like the current situation
when we collected the data in 2019
is that the entire
distribution of assets, etc
shifts sharply to the
left for the Rohingya
'cause they lost a lot,
whereas, in Bangladesh,
it remains similar.
And so, what you learn from the data is
one that, like people were,
like Rohingya and Bangladeshis
living on the side of the
border near the camps,
they were under very similar
comparable economic situations,
were doing similar things
in agriculture, right?
And then the Rohingya suddenly lose
all of their possessions.
And now, the distributions
are very different, right?
So, the point of highlighting this is,
one, you know, we also have to communicate
with my compatriots in Bangladesh on that,
as attitudes towards Rohingya
are changing over time,
have changed over time,
as people have gotten impatient
with a million people living
in camps in their midst,
and people are perceiving a
bunch of different problems
that even though we had
initially welcome them.
And so, to document this,
to show to my Bangladeshi
compatriots that,
look, these are people who
are just very similar to us,
it's just a bad luck
of being on the other side of the river,
suddenly, they've lost a lot.
And second is,
something that we need to
do a bit more work on is,
like connecting what we
see in the loss of assets
from pre to post 2017.
And the consistency of the reports
that we're getting in the
Bangladesh side of the border,
with the looting result
that Paula was showing
on the Myanmar side of the border.
- There is a question
on how we're planning
to use this satellite data.
I guess the answer is we don't know yet
because we're still in the
process of downloading it.
And we are waiting to see
whether the quality of the
image is gonna be good enough
for us to be able to run a regression
and look at, zoom in,
and see what happens
and see if we find an overlap
between those areas and the areas
from which our respondents
in our data set come from.
So that's something
that we're looking forward
to have our hands on,
but we haven't quite just yet.
- And to add to Paula's point, if I may,
on Susan's question about satellite data,
one particular avenue as
well that we can pursue,
and that we're hoping to is,
with sufficiently
fine-grained satellite data,
especially if we have time coverage
after the refugees have fled,
we can sort of get an
understanding of what the land
that has been appropriated
from Rohingya refugees,
is now being used for.
So for example,
is it now land that's being rewilded?
Has it been recultivated?
And if it's been recultivated,
that actually speaks to the
potential economic payoff
of displacing people from their lands.
So even if we can't use
our economist toolkits,
we might be able to do
some detective work,
to speak to the qualitative
nature of land use
after departure.
- I want to thank you for the paper.
For me, the value of a quantitative paper
and the use of large datasets,
and remote sensing for that matter,
is that it knits together
qualitative information
that we have from histories, commentaries,
from on the ground, right, observations.
I'm thinking, for example of
a 20-year set of documents
that the Korean human rights
group has been gathering
at the border,
of every incident that has taken place
over the last two decades.
It's an unbelievably valuable source.
It'd be interesting to
coordinate your observations
with that meticulous kind of data
that is available in an archival sets.
And so I'm interested in,
there are two questions I have.
I'm interested in why you
hit on the price of rice.
I mean, it's easily measurable, right?
It's available quite easily.
What other economic variables
did you you consider and reject, and why?
The qualitative information
that I have with respect to Burma
is that the seizure of land,
although occasionally it
is for irrigated rice land,
not just rice land that's suitable,
but irrigated rice land,
which is much more
valuable than rainfed rice,
that most of the seizures and looting
have been for minerals, right?
The effort to grab land that
can be used as plantations,
that overtaking of businesses
and orchards and so on.
And at least in the
qualitative information
that I'm familiar with,
the idea of just seizing
rice land or looting rice,
it appears almost not at all.
And if you've got evidence
that this appears in the
qualitative data as a motivation,
I would like to see more of that.
The other problem, I suppose,
is that you tend to treat the
Tatmadaw as a unitary actor.
My understanding is that
the regional commanders of the Tatmadaw,
and that was part of
the democratic opening
under Thein Sein,
was to give them a free hand
to grab whatever they wanted,
and to never bring any
corruption charges against them.
So we are dealing,
as we can see on the streets
in Rangoon in Mandalay now,
with individual police and
army seizing businesses,
looting and so on.
So your question of response,
let's say, to the Rohingya,
the ARSA attack, and so on,
there's a lot of your analysis
that treats the Tatmadaw
as a unitary actor,
and I think it is not correct
to treat the Tatmadaw as a unitary actor.
How that changes your analysis
I haven't quite thought through.
The last thing is,
it seems to me that,
and this is,
I don't want to make
this sound dismissive,
because it's not actually.
But I'm wondering how many
people on your team read
and speak Burmese?
And how much Burmese
sources have played a role
in what you've done?
Now, there's a workaround for this,
and I would like to pose
another question then.
There are lots of Burmese intellectuals
and journalists who've
spent several decades
working on the Tatmadaw
and trying to understand the
interior politics of Burma.
And you would be well-served
people like Min Zin, for one example.
These are people who I think
have you run your analysis by them,
and ask for their comments and criticisms?
And if you haven't,
I think it is professionally
a good thing for you to do.
- [Mushfiq] I was just
going to say, thanks Jim.
Would you be able to,
like if we send once the paper is ready.
So we're, you know, presenting something
that's a work-in-progress.
So once it's ready,
would you be able to connect
us with the right groups
who should be reading it?
Maybe forward it to them and?
Oh, you're on mute.
Sorry.
- I'd be happy to.
- [Mushfiq] Okay, excellent!
Thank you.
- Thank you so much for
your questions, Jim.
It's also personally very gratifying
to have you here
because you wrote one of my favorite books
on economic development,
"Seeing Like a State."
So it's an honor, frankly.
So in terms of what other
variables we considered,
we actually didn't run
any statistical inference
on other variables.
But we did do the intellectual
process of coming to rice,
and in particular, rainfed rice.
So that process actually involved
brainstorming other
agricultural commodities,
or mineral or extractive commodities,
that we could use a similar
type of approach to,
with the maps, for example.
And so, one set of endowments
that we did consider were oil,
gas and mineral resources.
And after looking at the maps,
it just so happened
that the geographical
spread of those resources
was more concentrated
than the rice gradient.
And it ultimately just became
quite a binary variable
off of which,
frankly, it was a statistical
feasibility issue.
It just wasn't giving us enough variation
to speak with our causal tools.
And of course you know,
that's a limitation of our field, frankly.
And so we did actually consider this idea
about rain fed versus irrigated rice.
And I think we landed on rain fed rice,
because it seemed like
one of the most broad-based,
held agricultural assets
that Rohingya populations would
have access to in the state.
However, you bring up a great point,
which is that, irrigated rice land
may be more of a target for expropriation.
So we actually have data on that,
and we could easily run
an additional statistical test,
rather than just rainfed rice suitability,
we could look at rice productivity
conditional on irrigation,
using a very similar technique.
So I think that's a fantastic suggestion,
and it's implementable.
So we'll go out and do it, absolutely.
- Thank you Jaya.
And I also want to thank James,
and I wanna speak to the second question
about whether we were aware
that the Tatmadaw is not a unitary actor.
I would say, I think as economists
we don't have the best
training on qualitative work
coming from South Asia.
But I've read a few papers
by mainstream myself,
and in fact, the part of the VAR analysis
that focuses on the connection
between ultra-nationalist
monks' hate speech
and military actions
comes from the paper by Min Zin
titled "Anti-Muslim
Violence in Burma: Why Now?"
Actually Min Zin inspired
a very important chunk of this paper.
In this particular article,
and I'm gonna refer to this
because it's the one
I've read the most time,
and it's more fresh in my mind,
I think that he did not
dismiss the possibility
or the argument that the
Tatmadaw is not a monolithic.
But he said, despite the fact
that it's not a monolithic,
we see systematic patterns
that are consistent
with what we have described in the paper.
Now, I fully acknowledge
that we need to complement this analysis
to capture in a much more accurate way
the dynamics that you have described.
Yes, there are some
regional dynamics at place.
Yes, there are elements
of The Tatmadaw response
that are clearly decided
at a regional level,
and we cannot at present
fully account for that.
Now that you've brought it to my attention
very explicitly, Jim,
I'm gonna get back to the data,
I'm gonna have another
look at the detail notes
of describing the events
that the ACLED data set collects.
And I'm going to try
to think about how we can
address these comments.
So I'm gonna need to think
a little bit more about it.
- [Mushfiq] And Jim, can you tell us,
I'm sure the the entire
audience would be interested.
So what's your history with
the engagement in Burma,
and when did you start,
or what type of work were you doing?
- You forced me to tell you how old I am.
I was in Burma before
any of you were born.
When I finished college,
for reasons that are rather humorous,
I had failed to go to work
on my senior economics thesis
at Williams College.
And my professor dismissed me
because I hadn't done enough
work in the fall semester.
I had fallen in love.
And I had to have someone adopt me
if I wanted to graduate
with honors in economics.
And I found a professor
who was interested in
Burmese economic development.
And he said if I work on
Burmese economic development,
he would adopt me.
And I said, fine.
And as I closed the door,
I asked myself, where is Burma?
I knew it was somewhere out there
between India and Thailand.
Any case, so I wrote a thesis
on Burmese economic development,
in particular, the Napin (unclear)
There was a five-year plan
that Burma was supposedly following then.
In any case, I had a rotary fellowship,
because rather than going to law school,
and spend a year in Burma,
fell completely in love with it,
and would have done a
dissertation on Burma
had it not closed up.
And I ended up working in Malaysia
because the Malay language is spoken
in four different
Southeast Asian countries.
And I knew that at least
one of them would be open
for fieldwork on the ground.
And so I'm in a sense by
accident a Southeast Asianist
and by accident a Burma specialists.
And I've kept up,
I've been going back.
I'm working on an eco-history
of the Irrawaddy River.
And I hope to write a small
book on the Irrawaddy River,
in which the life forms
of the Irrawaddy River
play a bigger role than Homo sapiens.
That is, I want it to be a
deep history of the river
as a life world of different life forms.
- [Mushfiq] Very nice, thank you.
- [James] Sure.
- [Mushfiq] So Teresa, should
we call the formal conference,
I mean, seminar to a close?
- Yes, definitely.
Yes, we're on time.
So thank you very much,
everyone for attending
and especially to Paula and her coauthors,
all of you for presenting
your results today.
Thanks a lot.
- Thank you for having us.
- [James] Thank you.